the deal field Chronicle is a pedestrian
real-time tactics game that suffers from
a lack of imagination essentially a
protracted series of tactical battles
dealfield chronicle's design falls into
an early routine from which it is
reluctant to deviate while its fantasy
world Apes the War Room politicking of
Game of Thrones with a focus on moving
the chess pieces at the expense of
credible character development flashes
of progress are seen in its combat and
the occasional voice dares to question a
realm ruled by Divine Authority but both
effects are ultimately futile crushed by
an exhausting and Relentless War Machine
thank you
on my way as the names suggests deofield
itself is a holy land God's country
where the hereditary Monarch is assured
by each new ruler supporting the mark of
the Blessed a birthmark of sorts that
appears to resemble a vein of precious
gems yet a fail king and the murder of
his Heir has caused a succession crisis
with factions forming around several
different candidates while neighboring
Empires I an opportunity to expand their
borders armies march across a map
straight out of the Game of Thrones
opening credits while those in command
conduct sober debate about their next
power play these are serious people
making serious decisions it seems to
imply everyone involved speaks as if
through clenched jaws and with curiously
little emotion a vocal performance that
is perhaps meant to indicate the gravity
of the situation but instead tends to
suggest everyone is just a bit bored
greetings everybody
my name is Walter Quinn Redditch
forgive my intrusion I had to flee
Southfield at a moment's notice
I should be glad to escort you to the
Redditch estate myself I will do what I
can to assist you in any way your
perspective on events is Through The
Eyes of Andreas ronderson who is the
Boyhood friend and servant of the
murdered Heir now grown up and leading a
band of mercenaries in the employee of
the crown Andreas makes for a dull lead
as he's disinclined to divulge his inner
thoughts while the ponderous often
humorless conversation he has with the
rest of the cast do little to warm you
to his plight or anyone else's for that
matter in Fairly typical jrpg style view
of the core cast look a day older than
18 yet carry themselves whether debating
strategy around a table or reflecting on
the last mission with World weariness of
a pragmatic veteran General it's
laborious stuff and serves mostly to
highlight the need for a quicker method
of skipping through each scene between
missions you explore the sparsely
decorated keep that serves as company HQ
collecting New Missions shopping for
weapons and consumables and upgrading
the party's abilities helpfully the map
shows where missions can be collected
and conversations can be held as well as
whether the merchant or research station
have new items available and you can
fast travel between locations in mere
seconds as you recruit new party members
this Hub area gradually becomes more
populated over time but despite the
presence of side missions to unlock
additional features in a new area it
fails to feel like a home not much more
than a collection of bland often empty
rooms the HQ is essentially a glorified
menu returning to the hub ought to be
accompanied by a sense of wonder at what
might have changed or developed instead
it's more of a weary resignation that
you're going to have to hop between hot
spots while clicking through a bunch of
boring dialogue
what's the matter is
how did you know it was me
[Music]
well you do have a certain Aura I've
come to know it rather well just as I
know from our recent battles that I need
to become stronger battles take place in
real time with the action pausing
automatically when you issue a movement
order or a command to use an ability
this can give proceedings a jarring stop
start feel but it does allow time to
think every step of the way and
crucially make small adjustments say
telling a character to step a few feet
to the side to avoid an incoming attack
the combat seems interesting at first
but fails to develop seemingly content
to tread the same ground from start to
finish surprises are limited to yet
another wave of enemies rather than any
attempt to chart new territory enemies
boil down to two types ranged and melee
with variations reduced stronger
versions and some slightly different
attacks your party members come in four
classes Soldier the defensive tank
Cavalier mobile damage Sharpshooter
range damage and magicker healing and
Buffs with some range damage these
characters require reasonably different
tactics to maximize their potential
you're not just telling everyone to
attack that enemy and sitting back it's
vital to tell your Cavalier to flank the
enemy and gain the Ambush attack bonus
or to have your soldier provoke specific
enemies into attacking her or to
instruct your magikar to cast Sanctuary
around the ground that your soldier is
holding or to have your Sharpshooter
fire off a stun shot to interrupt an
enemy preparing a special attack but as
you progress deeper the challenge of
combat doesn't escalate in interesting
ways sure there are a few more enemies
to face at once sure they have a couple
more tricks up their sleeve than mere
basic attacks and sure there's an odd
boss with multiple health bars but these
aren't that many more enemies those
extra tricks aren't all that new and
those bosses just take longer to kill
than demanding a novel approach for much
of the last half the game I tackled
every fight in the same way sticking to
the same core crew and only making minor
tweaks when necessary there was no need
to change because the missions weren't
presenting me with any new challenges
climactic encounters were handled in
identical fashion in a way that I
initially felt satisfying as if I'd
solved the problem of the game combat
before boredom set in at the absence of
any friction to stall my progress to the
end in the field Andreas might be the
group's leader but you can select any
characters to comprise the party of four
cleverly you're not limited to your
chosen four Once a battle gets underway
in the setup phase you assign a support
character to each primary party member
buffing their performance with passive
stat bonuses and allowing them to
activate the second character's special
abilities you can even a limited number
of times swap out a character primary or
support in the middle of a fight a
useful clutch move if someone's health
is dangerously low or the situation
calls for an ability specific to someone
else with upwards of a dozen characters
vying for battle time I recruited 14 in
my playthrough though there may be more
it's also just a smart way to ensure
that everyone is involved of course
there's still a tendency to stick with
your favorites particularly since the
primary party gains more XP but it eases
the burden of grinding missions you can
replay any once completed to tick off
sub-objectives and earn gold an XP to
allow under level character to catch up
the rudimentary map design exacerbates
the problem terrain type is not a factor
despite missions taking place in cities
farmlands snow fields deserts and swamps
that patch of water or mud on the ground
means nothing you can fire a ranged
weapon through or over any obstacle High
Ground is no Advantage everything is so
flattened out that the combat Arenas may
as well been blank spaces maybe this
wouldn't be such an issue if the mission
objective required more interesting
actions but they almost without
exception task you with killing all the
enemies sometimes you have to activate a
bridge to reach the next batch of
enemies occasionally there's an NPC to
escort across the map and you have to
kill all the enemies as you go and very
sparingly there's a point you have to
protect while killing all the enemies
even when the story introduces elements
that could potentially offer intriguing
alternative paths the mission format
doesn't change a nascent pro-democracy
government born of angry common folk is
quickly characterized as a band of thugs
and brutally squashed by your iron fist
at the behest of the king Empire
soldiers demi-human monsters the The
Walking Dead a group of angry peasant
Farmers they're all dealt with in the
same way deplore the mercs and Slaughter
anything that moves too many near
identical fights make for a tedious slog
and the late game story twists that
forestall the end credits only intensify
the fatigue
[Music]
the deal field Chronicle probably wants
to explore ideas around how power is
accumulated and how legitimacy is
granted with its Tales of Warring Lords
and Define rights but it never truly
engages with them characters hedge
around such issues expressing tentative
misgivings regarding the nobility of
their mission before carrying on
regardless similarly in brief
conversations it gestures at the
possibility of other ways to structure
Society but never actually entertains
them with Andreas and his mercenary
company the hammer that sees every
problem as a nail it makes for an
unsatisfying narrative Arc yet as you
deploy the same tactics across what may
as well be the same Battlefield against
pretty much the same enemies for the up
team time it's an effective metaphor for
the conservative and unimaginative game
design
[Music]
foreign